[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette 8 2024
deuxième numéro de la saison de votre
émission consacrée à l'actualité des
jeux de paris dans les yvelines voici le
programme de ce 24 février 2022 il va
prendre ses fonctions le 1er mars
grégory baugé le nouvel entraîneur de
l'équipe de france de sprint retraité
des pistes depuis un an le quadruple
médaillé olympique et nonuple champion
du monde se tourne vers une nouvelle
aventure en ligne de mire paris 2024 et
grégory baugé est notre invité retour
sur la semaine olympique et paralympique
la sixième édition s'est déroulée en
janvier partout en france à saint
quentin en yvelines les jeunes ont pu
prendre part à des activités sur les
trois sites des jo de l'agglomération
vélodrome golf national et coline
d'elancourt ont fait une application
pour former la génération 2024 et dans
paris région aventure le comité régional
du tourisme paris ile de france propose
des jeux autour de l'événement sportif
le but découvrir les structures et les
athlètes de manière ludique nous sommes
désormais à 8 183 jours des jeux
olympiques de paris c'est parti pour ce
7,8 2024
[Musique]
dernière échéance olympique avant paris
2024 les jo d'hiver se sont clôturées le
20 février à pékin les jeux
paralympiques e démarreront le 4 mars et
pour découvrir les sports d'hiver et de
montagne sans quitter les yvelines et
l'ufolep 78 organise pendant les
vacances sont winter tour ça se passe du
côté de la verrière le reportage de
mélanie poké et de nicolas landry
les sports d'hiver ce n'est pas qu'à la
montagne la verrière une centaine de
jeunes découvrent plusieurs disciplines
sportives toutes liées à cette époque de
l'année
j'aime bien pourquoi on s'amuse comme
mon pote on s'amuse tout c'est trop bien
je trouve que la patinoire est assez
amusant mais c'est pas de la vraie glace
le hockey j'ai beaucoup adoré et le
choeur lee hooker jr toi la carline
j'aimerais voilà ça passe encore à
l'organisation du fola 78 fédération
sportive multisports curling patinage
escalade ou encore oh quel objectif
faire découvrir des sports originaux
avec en ligne de mire paris 2024 on a
souhaité rassembler sur un site
qui s'y prêtait celui de la rpd de la
verrière un ensemble d'activités qui
sont en phase avec les jeux olympiques
de pékin sur lesquels on retrouvait à
peu près toutes les activités de
montagne qui s'adresse plus
particulièrement un public qui n'a
peut-être pas la chance de pouvoir en
profiter ça le 10 % des français vont
tous qui chaque année 40 % ne sont même
jamais allé ça permet de découvrir des
sports ça permet de travailler la
cohésion des équipes ça permet pendant
les vacances avec le centre aéré de
s'aérer la tête et de se dépenser au
plus près de chez soi donc on a
effectivement un partenariat gagnant
gagnant autour des valeurs du sport il
est important de mutualiser nos les
moyens un petit peu pour pouvoir aussi
faire vivre je dirais les instants
éducatif que doivent avoir les enfants
les vacances apprenantes et plus on
s'associe ensemble et plus on développe
nos partenariats la ville s'est
rapproché essentiellement des centres de
loisirs structures de jeunesse et
certaines écoles le winter tour se
déroule jusqu'au 4 mars prochain
toujours pendant ces vacances d'hiver
l'équipe de france juniors de breaking
est accueillie aux mureaux pour un stage
première sortie d'une tournée nationale
qui doit se dérouler partout en france
au programme beaucoup d'entraînement et
une exhibition qui s'est déroulée ce
mercredi 23 février au collègue pablo
neruda elle l'occasion pour ces jeunes
de rencontrer le public et de mesurer
l'engouement un peu plus de deux ans des
jo le break dance sera pour la première
fois une discipline olympique avec comme
épreuve des battles organisés place de
la concorde à paris les propos
recueillis par michael et demi d'euros
c'est cool autant de monde ça fait plein
de personnes qu'ils encouragent et tout
ça motive du coup franchement c'est
génial avec les jeux olympiques vraiment
ça donne une ampleur qu'on n'aurait
jamais pensé c'est pas du tout ça fins a
pas du tout été créé pour ça la bosse
donc vraiment c'est cool de voir une
évolution qui passe de quelque chose qui
a été fait dans les rues extra sur des
cartons à l'arrivée aux jeux olympiques
donc pouvoir être médailles olympiques
et cetera vraiment c'est quelque chose
dont je me serais attendu et qui
vraiment je trouve peut être bénéfique
c'est fait de la bonne manière but c'est
de venir un déjà s'entraîner dans un
dans des infrastructures spécialisées
pour le breaking et y en a ici aux
mureaux parce que c'est parti pour être
centre de préparation aux jeux breaking
mais de aussi surtout une ouverture vers
l'extérieur vers le grand public
sensibilisé aux breaking ce soit à
travers les lexiques le lexique du
breaking les appellations mais aussi les
mouvements là le format de compétition
les battles et tout ça et c'est ce qu'on
a fait aujourd'hui il ya une petite
initiation il ya eu un battle ils ont pu
voir un entraînement de breaking il
reportages plus complet à retrouver dans
l'émission 7 8 sport ce 28 février sur
tv 78 c'est l'un des quatre sites
olympiques yvelinois la colline
d'elancourt accueillera les épreuves de
vtt en 2024 avant le démarrage des
travaux prévu sur place pour la fin de
l'année il faut répondre aux enjeux
concernant l'écologie l'aménagement et
l'héritage du lieu une concertation
s'est déroulée il ya quelques mois et
deux nouveaux temps forts sont
programmés les précisions de bixente
mais rien senti steban elle accueillera
les jeux olympiques de paris 2024 mais
avant la colline d'elancourt devra être
aménagé plus de 350 ils en ont participé
ces derniers mois des concertations
avant la validation du projet par
l'agglomération objectif transmettre
leurs interrogations leurs inquiétudes
et apporter de nouvelles idées nous
allons ensuite reçus m le résultat des
études à un vote qui serait deux fois ci
à une prise de position qui sera
électronique pour la population qui aura
lieu pendant tout le printemps 2022 à
nouveau nous allons pouvoir débriefer
l'ensemble des interventions avant la
fermeture du site pour travaux en 2023
ces discussions ont permis de confirmer
les impératifs en vue de la
transformation et ce qu'ont donné les
différentes études réalisées et le
retour des habitants bien c'est la même
la même orientation la volonté de
conserver un parc ouvert à la population
vers vertueux est donc un maximum
d'efforts a été mis à été confirmés
parlent résultat des études de fait
auprès de la population de la volonté de
densifier encore la protection de
l'environnement c'est pourquoi les ce
qu'on appelle la compensation écologique
sur ce site sur un certainement une des
composants station écologique les plus
exemplaires que de tout paris 2024 autre
interrogation l'héritage après les jeux
et comment mettre en relief le futur
espace sportif le site a été pensé pour
pouvoir une fois que les jeux olympiques
sont terminés donc il soit ouvert au
public mais également que l'ensemble des
infrastructures invisible tout ce qui
permet techniquement de pouvoir très
rapidement réinstaller un lieu d'accueil
des preuves de vtt soit présent tout ce
qui est passage des câbles tout ce qui
est r techniques etc mais ça sera
absolument invisible permettront demeure
de pouvoir bien positionné à nouveau
très rapidement un village pour un
week-end de vtt et pourquoi pas une voie
que ya par exemple les championnats du
monde de vtt en plus du vtt à elancourt
dans les yvelines accueilleront le bmx
le cyclisme sur piste et sur route le
pentathlon moderne le golf et les sports
équestres cette épreuve olympique dont
celle d'elancourt sous l'oeil de la
grande dame de fer
la colline d'elancourt point culminant
d'île de france 2 131 mètres où les
travaux devraient démarrer à la fin de
l'année le projet prévoit la création
d'une piste olympique de quatre
kilomètres elle reprendra à 95% des
chemins existants une grande promenade
piétonne qui fera le tour de la colline
sera également réalisée en partie basse
une prairie aménagé à l'ouest de la
colline ça c'est pour 2024 mais
l'objectif est de donner un futur à ce
site en 2025 la phase héritage entrera
en action la piste olympique sera
conservé mais complété de parcours
intermédiaire est facile pour
démocratiser la pratique du vtt un
espace dédié au bmx trottinette roller
et skate ouvrira en bas des pistes et le
pommeau traque enfin la colline sera
pourvue d espaces de sport détente
loisirs et de promenade pour les
familles et puis concernant le
calendrier soli deo qui est
l'établissement public qui financent
superviser livre les ouvrages de paris
2024 doit présenter un projet détaillé
et les habitants pourront de nouveau
donné leur avis par un vote électronique
entre avril et mai prochains les travaux
devraient se dérouler en deux phases
jusqu en avril 2000 24 entre temps en
septembre 2000 23 un test event sera
organisée organisé sur place pour
expérimenter la piste olympique en
conditions réelles et pour la partie
héritage c'est à dire l'ouverture de la
colline aux habitants c'est prévu après
les jeux en mars 2000 25 au terme d'une
dernière phase de travaux
[Musique]
un peu plus d'un an après sa retraite
sportive le tigre se lance dans une
nouvelle aventure grégory baugé a été
nommé tout récemment entraîneur national
du sprint de l'équipe de france de
cyclisme sur piste on a la chance est de
le recevoir vous le voyez en
visioconférence bonsoir grégory baugé
bonsoir merci d'être merci d'être avec
nous dans cette émission 7,8 2024 prise
de fonction tout prochainement ce sera
le 1er mars officiellement dans quel
état d'esprit abordez vous ce nouveau
rôle
oui
déjà cc je suis très content j'ai très
content et fier conduit c'est trop pour
cette proposition après c'est quand même
lui remet en réfléchissant c'est pas
cette nuit là j'ai cette proposition est
acceptée dit laurent demain mais en tout
cas non je suis très content alors oui
officiellement ça sera à partir du 1er
mars mais j'ai déjà déjà commencé depuis
le début d'année à prendre mes marques
donc au nom je suis très content et puis
à comines et ça fait j'ai quitté milan
le milieu et j'ai arrêté ma carrière y
un nom et un enracinement à moi un an
après moi je suis au poste d'entraîneur
national d'espagne je suis aussi très
content et à hasard du calendrier on
vous reçoit le jour où le britannique
jason kenny annonce aussi la fin de sa
carrière à neuf médailles olympiques
pour lui 7 en or et comme vous il va
prendre les rênes de la sélection sprint
mais pour les britanniques du coup le
duel sur la piste va se poursuivre en
coulisses
effectivement j'ai appris aussi sa
nomination a quasiment une semaine en
même temps que moi bah bah c'est tant
mieux pour eux mais pour l'équipe
d'angleterre et comme j'ai dit on a un
lien commun on a eu l'habitude de se
battre pour des titres mondiaux des
titres olympiques donc à nous de faire
en sorte que les coureurs de nos équipes
respectives puissent aller chercher des
résultats votre palmarès grégory baugé
on ne le présente plus mais je vais
quand même les greens et pour nos
téléspectateurs c'est l'un des plus
fournis en francs neuf titres de
champion du monde dont quatre en vitesse
individuelle quatre médailles olympiques
trois en argent dont la vitesse
individuelle à londres en 2012 et une en
bronze après cette carrière auréolée de
titre justement vous avez dit c'est une
décision mûrement réfléchie qu'est ce
qui vous a poussé à accepter ce nouveau
défi ce
qu'est ce qu'il me
pousser bah forcément leu leu en fait ça
fait aussi j'ai arrêté il ya un an mais
ça fait cinq ans que j'entraîne aussi
auprès notamment l'athlète paralympique
à décrocher deux belles médailles de
bronze l'année dernière aux jeux
paralympiques de tokyo et en vivent un
peu en vivent un peu les jeux olympiques
avant les jeux paralympiques la
perspective à vous le savez il ya les
jeux olympiques à à paris bien sûr je me
suis dit faut que j'aie faut que
j'arrive à tout en continuant avec mes à
pouvoir aider
aider d'autres athlètes c'était inédit
qui met mais traversy a traversé dans la
tête et j'ai eu cette proposition fin
d'année et voit je me suis dit what the
wall j'y vais j'y vais en plus parce que
parce que je connais en je connais
l'équipe de france le staff les athlètes
surtout il ya des athlètes talentueux
donc je pense que avec moi venu ils
peuvent passer un cap et l'athlète
handisport dont vous parliez c'est marie
patouiller que vous avez effectivement
entraîner deux médailles de bronze pour
elle sur les derniers jeux paralympiques
est de tokyo il ya aussi la présence de
florian rousseau qui est l'un des autres
grands palmarès du cyclisme sur piste
français qui a été nommé en plus
directeur du programme olympique et qui
a été votre entraîneur ça vous a aussi
peut-être totalement convaincu sa
présence de former un duo avec lui si
bien sûr c'est pas
oui c'est clair que ça a beaucoup penché
dans la balance donc il a un gros rôle
au sein de la fédération
je pense voici qui m'a proposé ce qui me
connaît
on se connaît depuis très très longtemps
donc ça a été déjà en tant que coureur
et puis après après en tant qu
entraîneur entraîné
mais c'est clair ça jouer dans mon choix
je pense qu'il va pouvoir faire évoluer
les choses et moi même en tant
qu'entraîneur pouvoir ou s'y faire
bouger les choses et concentré sur ma
partie ce qui ce qui l entraînement vos
expériences respectives à vous à florian
rousseau ça ça va être la vraie carte à
jouer pour l'équipe de france de
cyclisme sur piste on aura l'occasion
d'en parler dans un sens qui est très
jeune c'est ça aide aussi d'avoir de
l'expérience
oui oui c'est important il a eu ce rôle
de d'entraîneur après je pense moi je
vois que du positif ça fait ça fait un
an que j'ai arrêté ça fait cinq ans que
j'entraîne je me suis passé mes diplômes
aussi auparavant
et puis je connais aussi l'adversité jeu
j'ai des idées par rapport à voile à
des évolutions que que l'on doit
apporter pour nos athlètes donc voilà
après comme j'ai dis tout net mon
expérience va falloir à partager avec
les a créés était vraiment qu'on se dit
partagée mais même plus là transpirer
sur les athlètes en fait parce que c'est
dans l'habitude de deux s'entraîner
megharia d'une méthode ya deux façons de
s'entraîner et l'investissement se lever
tous les jours en six ans voit c'est moi
le plus fort pour pouvoir passer des
paliers plus rapidement possible et il
faut pas se le cacher on y aussi les
championnats du monde à paris en fin
d'année donc c'est un point d'étape
aussi important même si c'est pas le
plus important parce qu'on sait très
bien là l'objectif c'est les jeux
olympiques à paris mais c'est tout ça
que je vais jouer devoir pouvoir
ben voilà jrce euros sur toute une
équipe il n'y a pas que les coureurs et
le staff aussi donc il ya quand même pas
mal de personnes ont sans doute autour
des athlètes qu'il faut réussir à
fédérer tout le monde est bon sur
l'objectif est d'en seul but d'être
d'être champion olympique mais vous
parlez des prochaines échéances les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste au vélodrome nationale ce sera en
octobre y aura bien sûr est les jeux
olympiques les jeux olympiques de paris
juste un dernier mot sur l'équipe de
france je le disais une équipe de france
très jeune que vous connaissez en plus
je vous ai côtoyé les athlètes en tant
qu' en tant que coéquipier on peut citer
le trio à la vitesse par équipes qui a
été en bronze lors des dernières lors
des derniers jo sébastien adige et ryan
et la halle florian égrène beau 24 23 et
21 ans on cite aussi chez les féminines
mathilde de gros 22 ans on sent qu'il ya
un gros potentiel qu'est-ce-qui qu'est
ce qui manque est-ce qu'il faut un peu
plus d'expérience un déclic
supplémentaires je pense notamment à
mathilde de gros qui avait plutôt déçu
sur les derniers jeux olympiques et qui
est une athlète très exposé
médiatiquement
oui bien sûr on vous l'avait dit il ya
un groupe assez jeune donc je les
connais tous j'ai côtoyé en tant qu' en
tant que courant donc je les connais
c'est un désavantage eux connaissent ils
les points forts et les points faibles
de chacun donc c'est améliorer les
points forts et gommer les lespwa fait
mais je sais que sur quel levier de
pouvoir pouvoir jouer pour tout ça ils
sont jeunes mais moi ils ont besoin
aussi de 2,2 de confiance et puis
surtout à mon sens beaucoup de beaucoup
de travail parce qu'on a rien sans rien
et vraiment essayé de tout optimisé et
en prenant compte que c'est pas que
l'entraînement pis c'est pas que l'on
traîne de musculation ccc d'un nutrition
cc c'est la récupération toutes ces
choses là où va falloir être minutieux
et rien négliger parce que en même temps
si on est vraiment conscient on part
voilà en ayant les pieds sur terre on
n'est pas la meilleure nation n'est plus
la meilleure nation est ce que je veux
c'est de refaire passer un palier d'un
que c'est clair que comme j'ai déjà pu
le retenir comme discours c'est que la
performance qui sera faite aux jeux
olympiques basse et c'est ça demande
beaucoup dans le quotidien mais c'est
dès maintenant qu'il faut prendre en
compte toute dernière chose on se
rappelle de mondiaux très réussie en
2015 à saint-quentin-en-yvelines y avait
eu sept médailles dont 5 en or pour
l'équipe de france il y avait eu
notamment la vitesse individuelle pour
us qui a déjà un objectif de médailles
pour les prochains là qui vont arriver
non non non c'est clair c'est fait un
événement un très gros événement un
point d'étape un port important après
non je ne veux pas leur mettre la
pression tout de suite
c'était aussi notre équipe d est d'aider
des athlètes plus expérimenté donc on
encore on a encore le temps de faire
monter la sauce mais y'a pas un instant
non là c'est simple point d'étape dont
c'est très bien pour l'instant l'heure
est au travail
avant les jo de 2024 on l'a bien compris
on vous souhaite plein de réussite dans
cette nouvelle mission grégory baugé
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci
beaucoup merci pour l'invitation et puis
je vous rappelle qu'on prochaine à une
prochaine en plus de nombreux titres
vous êtes désormais le nouvel entraîneur
du sprint de cette équipe de france de
cyclisme sur piste
[Musique]
parler du vélo de route nationale avec
grégory baugé elle s'est déroulée
justement au vélodrome nationale mais
pas que la sixième édition est de la
semaine olympique et paralympique s'est
tenu en janvier dernier pour faire
découvrir les trois sites saint
quentinois de paris 2024 est de nombreux
ateliers sportifs étaient organisées par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines retour avec bixente maya
santisteva une justine brasier et julien
leroy
saint quentin en yvelines une terre de
vélo qui accueillera en 2024 le vélo sur
route sur piste le bmx et le vtt la
semaine olympique était l'occasion de
faire découvrir aux jeunes ces
disciplines à commencer par le bmx au
vélodrome nationale c'est une activité
qui est peu connu mais qu'on a la chance
d'avoir vraiment à proximité sur notre
territoire c'est une activité nouvelle à
sensations fortes que les élèves aiment
beaucoup donc c'est génial pour u2 le
pouvoir l'expérimenté aujourd'hui une
initiation encadrée par un invité de
marque romain racines deuxième de la
dernière coupe du monde de bmx en
d'élite c'est un plaisir de pouvoir
partager mon expérience avec eux et
également avec les jeunes de la hesse
qui encadrent eux aussi leur but c'est
de le faire dès que découvrir en fait
toute la piste et que bah il soit ils
prennent plaisir en fait à découvrir le
site
deux jours plus tard vendredi 28 janvier
c'était au tour du futur site d'accueil
du vtt la colline d'elancourt
d'accueillir des classes
au programme pas de vélo mais en
parcours de 5 km sur la thématique
environnementale
sur ce parcours il y avait plusieurs
panneaux d'information qu'ils étaient
disposés donc les élèves se s'arrêter à
chaque panneau découvrez les
informations qui étaient affichés et
emplissaient un petit quizz sur chaque
point il avait des questions alors sur
la faune et la flore sur l'aménagement
du site sur les épreuves olympiques est
donc arrivé en haut de la colline on
vérifier qu'il est bien remplie le quiz
et et on leur offrait un petit goûter on
nous a expliqué le petit parcours avec
les élèves retournent et les anneaux
répondre à des questions il avait un
petit livret à remplir au fur et à
mesure c'était très sportif
j'ai une classe qui bouge pas mal autre
épreuve de paris 2024 le golf a lui
aussi été mise à l'honneur pendant la
semaine au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
[Applaudissements]
et les rendez vous vont se multiplier
pour faire grimper doucement mais
sûrement l'engouement jusqu'au 26
juillet 2024 et date de l'ouverture des
jeux olympiques de paris est le comité
d'organisation a confirmé en décembre
dernier ce qui était un secret de
polichinelle est la cérémonie se
déroulera bien sur la scène pour la
première fois de l'histoire olympique
donc l'événement sera hors d'un stade
que faut-il savoir de cette cérémonie
d'ouverture et bien elle se commencera
elle débutera par le défilé des athlètes
qui assisteront et participeront au
spectacle les 10500 sportif et 206
délégations internationales prendront
place sur 160 bateaux un show de cette
heure le parcours s'élancera du pont
d'austerlitz à devant le jardin des
plantes pour un défilé fluvial d'est en
ouest de 6 km est la déambulation
passera devant quelques grands monuments
notre-dame la conciergerie le louvre le
musée d'orsay sans oublier la tour
eiffel les embarcations navigueront soit
8 à 10 pouces se tiendront des
spectacles danseurs sur les toits
orchestre flottant hologramme drones
seront au menu des festivités
et puis le grand final avec l'allumage
de la flamme olympique au trocadéro sera
installée la tribune officielle garni
est de 120 chefs d'état enfin six cent
mille spectateurs seront attendus sur
les quais hauts ils pourront profiter
d'accès gratuit c'est une première sur
les cabas en revanche entre le pont
d'austerlitz et le pont d'iéna les
places seront payantes 80 écrans géants
et sonorisé permettront de suivre la
cérémonie partout dans la capitale enfin
la diffusion télévisée n'est également
pas oublier on parle d'un milliard de
téléspectateurs tout de même avec un
dispositif novateur notamment la
présence de caméras embarquées sur les
bateaux pour être au plus près des
athlètes et davantage de médiatisation
des compétitions féminines et aller vers
plus d'égalité dans la pratique
l'opération nationale sport féminin
toujours s'est déroulé est du 14 au 20
février dernier au niveau national les
femmes représentent 38% de la pratique
sportive le chiffre recule même à 28 %
dans le département des yvelines selon
le comité départemental olympique et
sportif mario ibra responsable de la
commission sport féminin était notre
invité il ya quelques jours sur tv 78 il
est très important de montrer des
sportives en action sur les met dans
tous les médias parce que il n'y en a
pas assez et de montrer des sportifs de
haut niveau c'est quelque chose aussi
qui peuvent faire venir qui peuvent
faire adhérer des femmes et vais revenir
des femmes aux sports donc c'est
important que l'on montre que les femmes
ont toute leur place dans le sport est
une très très grande place qui elle
portait pourrait pourrait porter les
couleurs très haut les couleurs de la
france dans les prochaines années la
mort pas yens et jade le corps 16 ans a
remporté le titre de championne de
france cadette de cross c'était en
novembre dernier entre entraînements et
rigueur les licenciés de l'entente
athlétique de saint quentin en yvelines
est un véritable espoir pour sa
discipline son portrait par céline
charles michael et demi d'euros et la
voix de nicolas d'ombrés
avec quatre à cinq entraînements par
semaine les efforts de jade le corps on
pays elle a su saisir la première place
du podium dans la catégorie cadette lors
des championnats de france de cross en
novembre dernier quand je suis parti et
je pensais vraiment pas faire fusionnent
je visais un top 5 et bas pendant à quoi
me suis vraiment senti bien donc j'ai vu
qu'on commence à détacher des autres
filles donc après je pars si
sa fille spécialisée dans le demi fond
elle a commencé l'athlétisme à 11 ans
performance et chrono surprenant la
jeune femme qui s'entraîne au club de
l'entente athlétique de saint quentin en
yvelines ne cesse d'impressionner
j'ai commencé parce qu'on m'a repéré en
sixième au cross et du coup après je me
suis inscrit au club et je faisais un
peu toutes les spécialités
et après en donner j'ai voulu me
spécialiser en demi fond parce que c'est
ce que je préférais début je
m'entraînais comme ça et puis on a
commencé à faire plus d'entraînement a
programmé plus de compet de minimes 2
elle a montré des qualités qui sont
rares
arrate de quelques dixièmes le record de
france sur 1000 m pour sa deuxième année
de demi fond et puis et puis l'an
dernier en cadettes pareil à la sortie
des chronos
très surprenant
ok je m'attendais pas forcément dès que
le coup de feu retentit ça devient ça
devient une athlète qui est très forte
mentalement
qui comme je dis qu'il va à la guerre
quand elle a pas peur de la bagarre et
de
et
chercher les filles est vraiment de se
faire mal en compétition véritable
espoir pour la suite jade rêve comme ces
exemples gimmi gressier où hugo est
d'atteindre les jeux olympiques je pense
qu'en tombe de fer regio mais bon je
pense que j'ai le temps et de continuer
à faire des sélections bas à mon âge le
1500 et les légions de 1028 j'aimerais
bien los angeles chose que je pourrais
peut être dans les meilleures
européennes
bref méreau place de sa catégorie une
motivation à toute épreuve et des
résultats qui suivent la championne qui
fait jusqu'à trois compétitions par mois
pourrait rapidement gravir les échelons
objectif paris 2024 pour rima ayadi
l'histoire est folle et pourtant elle
est vraie l'athlète qui a débuté la boxe
à seulement 26 ans a connu une
progression fulgurante championne de
france en 2020 l'habitante de poitiers a
conservé le 19 février aux mureaux sa
ceinture wbc continental des légers
victoire aux points contre l'ukrainienne
et medvedev qu avec sept victoires en
sept matches au compteur dont une par ko
la sociétaire du club bam héritage
ambitionne désormais une ceinture
européenne avant de tenter l'aventuré au
oui c'est une ceinture européenne
qu'on aimerait organiser en juin
toujours aux mureaux on est très attaché
à organiser dans les yvelines ça permet
à nos partenaires de pouvoir venir nous
voir et profiter de la soirée et
j'espère que ça se fera parce que vous
avez les les jeux olympiques aussi de
2024 qui vont se dérouler à paris ce que
vous vous l'avez dans un coin de votre
tête à bac + 4/5 ans de macaques c'est
le seul objectif qui est fixé et on va
tout faire pour être sûr paris 2024 dès
la rentrée je réintègre pleinement
l'équipe de france pour faire un maximum
de stages et de compétition pour
retrouver l'essentiel de la boxe
olympique qui n'est pas la même et c'est
clairement dans l'ambition de participer
au jeu il s'agissait bien de rima ayadi
un son nom ne s'était pas affiché sur
l'écran de nombreux athlètes pourront en
tout cas à s'inspirer de l'exemple de
christopher six parties comme remplaçant
aux jeux de tokyo l'été dernier libye
noah est bien revenue avec une médaille
de bronze en équitation au concours
complet par équipes le cavalier nous a
ouvert les portes de ses écuries à gaz
rend il a livré amatil de franck où est
michael lmi noro quelques secrets des
méthodes de travail pour préparer ses
chevaux aux grandes échéances comme vous
le savez aujourd'hui on est dans les
écuries de christopher 6 alors moi je
suis passionnée d'équitation j'en fais
depuis que je suis toute petite et
aujourd'hui et va on va essayer de
tenter de savoir comment décrocher une
médaille olympique le parti
[Musique]
vous
alors comment ça s'est passé cette
première séance de saut depuis bas les
jo de tokyo et moi je suis très content
il n'a pas oublié comment on faisait pas
vous repasser au dessus des barres
effectivement la dernière fois qu'il
avait sauté un obstacle c'était à tokyo
il a eu une grande pause j'ai pris le
parti de le faire un vrai break pour
qu'ils récupèrent de cette échéance là
là maintenant les jours commencent à
être comptés avant le début de saison
2022 donc faut s'y remettre et voilà
j'ai pris mon temps parce que c'est un
très bon sauteur il n'a pas besoin de
sauter beaucoup avant le premier
concours
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
astuces de pros je sais pas est ce que
vous avez des manies est ce que vous
faites des choses régulière un côté
enfin travail que vous faites tous les
jours est-ce que vous avez des petites
d'astuces de champion olympique
déjà alors je sais pas s'il ya beaucoup
d'astuces mais je fais au travail
pratiquement tous les jours ils ont un
jour de huf par semaine ou là ils n'ont
pas la selle sur le dos ils vont co op
haddock mais sinon on monte dessus 6
jours sur 7 et après on varie beaucoup
le travail par contre ils vont alterner
entre du travail sur le dressage du
travail à l'obstacle des extérieurs ou
juste aller se balader et puis après il
ya aussi les les préparations les galops
pour la mise en s'immolant souffle à
conditions et tout ça donc j'essaye
vraiment de varier le plus possible pour
pas que le cheval il soit blasé par le
travail en fait plus on va varier plus
on va varier le travail plus il va être
content de travailler voilà maintenant
vous savez tout pour devenir champion
olympique ou presque parce que je pense
qu'il ya une sacrée dose de talent à
avoir tout de même
[Musique]
et
enfin avec les jeux de paris qui
approchent l'objectif du comité
d'organisation et de créer une
génération 2024 ces jeunes qui
connaîtront cet événement sur le sol
français peut-être une seule fois dans
leur vie pour ce faire le comité
régional du tourisme paris ile de france
a déployé une première aventure
virtuelle autour des sports olympiques
et paralympiques à l'état vivre et grâce
à l'application paris-région aventure il
vous était déjà possible de parcourir
l'île de france au travers de ces cités
personnages historiques l'application
paris-région aventure se tournent
désormais vers les jo de 2024 de
n'importe où dans les yvelines et même
dans le monde vous pouvez vous frotter à
ce jeu de piste géant et découvrir les
athlètes emblématiques de leur
discipline ainsi que les étoiles
montantes c'est permettre en fait je que
les enfants puissent connaître ce qu'est
la magie des jeux c'est finalement les
préparer à la magie des jeux c'est parce
que c'est finalement qui qui ensuite
deviendront les ambassadeurs de notre
région aussi bien auprès de leurs
propres familles quand ils deviendront
grands et auprès également de leurs amis
pourront venir d'autres pays allez on va
s'y essaie une fois que vous avez lancé
l'application le jeu vous donne le choix
entre deux personnages un personnage
masculin un personnage féminin tom ou
emma on va choisir tom pour cette
aventure une fois le jeu charge et vous
accédez à une carte interactive
les sites qui vont nous intéresser se
trouve à l'ouest de l'ile-de-france sur
la partie gauche de votre écran va donc
zoomer sur ces sites et cliquez sur
l'une des flamme olympique
et la rédaction de tv 78 on ne va pas
aller très loin puisqu'on va se rendre
tout de suite au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines sur la carte
qui est l'un des sites hôte des épreuves
de paris 2024 à chaque fois votre
personnage apparaît sur la carte vous
avez un petit joystick virtuel sur le
côté bas de votre écran qui vous permet
de vous déplacer vous le voyez
dans votre espace
il suffit d'aller voir le maître du jeu
le maître du jeu va vous lancer un défi
à chaque fois trouvé trois objets en
rapport direct avec le site olympique en
question est là il s'agit de trouver un
vélo un casque et des lunettes c'est
parti
ça leur ouvre des clés du stade ou du
lieu et une fois à l'intérieur il ya un
mix entre des images immersif qui leur
demande de chercher aussi des objets on
leur demande de scanner certains
éléments de répondre à des quizz ce qui
permet de répondre à un certain nombre
de défis pour découvrir du coup les
athlètes et les collectionner et quels
athlètes se cache derrière cet indice il
s'agissait d'axel etienne athlètes de
bmx bien sûr et une petite description
vous aident à découvrir cet athlète axel
etienne qui a déjà un palmarès fourni
mais qui est encore très jeune 23 ans et
qui sera l'une des pépites à suivre bien
sûr pour paris 2024 à chaque fois que la
khl a été trouvé une petite question
vous est posée ensuite je vais pas y
répondre parce que ce serait vous donner
toutes les clés pour réussir ce jeu il
faut que vous puissiez découvrir par
vous même et bien sûr vous pouvez
découvrir l'ensemble des autres sites
saint quentinois le golf national situé
à guyancourt la colline d'elancourt qui
va accueillir les épreuves de vtt du
côté de la commune d'hallencourt
forcément mais aussi la ville de
versailles qui va accueillir plusieurs
épreuves en tout en ile de france se
sont dit cette aventure qui vous emmène
à la découverte de paris 2024 on a les
sites de paris intra muros on a le stade
de france on a le parc des princes on a
à la base aquatique de vaires sur marne
on a évidemment grand nombre des
principaux sites de compétition de paris
2024 l'application est gratuite elle est
disponible sur l'appstore et sur google
plaît c'est à votre tour
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro de 7,8
2024 merci de votre fidélité on se
retrouve dans trois mois pour une
prochaine miss une prochaine émission à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]